let me let me jump to this story from
newsweek because this is is relevant
newsweek reports u.s expects kiev to
fall in days
as ukraine's source warns of
encirclement so you've got multiple
reporters on the story saying three
different u.s officials ukraine's
capital will fall within i think they
say 96 hours and within a week the
ukrainian government will fall to russia
this bad
it's very bad however
it could be
better than the alternative ukraine
falling could be an end to the conflict
outright
sure yeah i mean
we
these situations are are terrible
because they're incredibly complex and
you don't know the next moves of
of some of these people you know what
happens when ukraine falls is is putin
satisfied that's a great question you
know this is my next question is he
satisfied or
you know and and do we just if he is
satisfied do we just take that loss yeah
you know and and what are the
repercussions of that you know i mean
walking away from america
what are we worried about now the issue
is
nato these these western european
nations want cheaper energy
russia controls a lot of the energy
flowing in
the the craziest thing is one of one of
one of the moves that joe biden made uh
in the past couple of days was to
sanction the nord stream to pipeline
which goes from russia to germany
he sanctioned that
but he was the one who lifted the
sanctions on in the first place they
tried to appease after he shut down the
keys
exactly
they tried to appease russia it didn't
work
russia
vladimir putin sees the appeasement
they're like okay we're going to lift
these sanctions you can do your pipeline
just don't invade ukraine otherwise
we'll put them back in place and putin
went
oh yeah sure because we were fine with
those sanctions yep you know that they
weren't affecting them that greatly so
he said okay sure
ben shapiro made a really really great
point he said uh paraphrasing
that the us
that our our culture is so materialistic
yes that we think sanctions inhibiting
their ability to buy things will stop
them russia wants to rebuild the russian
empire china johnson said today joe
biden said it today that he didn't think
the sanctions were going to do anything
there's a clip of him coming out and
saying yeah well we didn't think
sanctions were going to do anything
anyway
you know so it's it's a it's it's all
for show
he know he knows that that's not going
to be enough of a deterrent ben shapiro
made the really interesting point sorry
to cut you off i just have to throw this
out there but ben shapiro made the
really interesting point that russia has
something higher to work for that the
u.s no longer has he's like we are so
materialistic we care about faster cars
we care about levi's we don't actually
care about our country or like any kind
of overarching moral framework and they
do and that's something we can't they've
been struggling for how long right you
know and this is this is
if you're if you're russian
you know and if you're in the russian
government and if you're vladimir putin
you're seeing this as a chance to you
know like you said rebuild or restore
whatever that empire was in his mind i
think and we're not looking at it from
that perspective right we've in america
we've never experienced that you know
the worst hardship that we've
experienced financially in terms of in
terms of you know hardship was the
depression and we made it out of that
okay and that that elapsed far into our
memories you know
these people have been living
under harsh conditions for a really long
time so they're looking they're looking
at these opportunities to
capitalize and become a more powerful
country become more economically stable
you know so
what dog do we have in the fight here
hmm i think if he was smart putin he is
that he would take what he takes out of
ukraine and then that's it he moves on
and he's remembered as vladimir the
great like you could
but if you push it to your feet
honestly do you if you were a betting
man would you bet that he would do that
no i wouldn't yeah because otherwise
he's going to get the world declare war
on him he's got to be careful no no i i
think i think you know we learned a
little bit at all we learned a lesson
here just two days ago we're like ah he
won't go for kia that's ridiculous he
won't go
96 hours yeah yeah yeah we we were
sitting here saying it'll never happen
and then last night it's like the show
ends and i got a message from luke and
he's like all caps during the show too
yeah
russia's invaded and i'm like well then
yeah we were hard and fast because if he
took a little bit now and then waited
and later tried went for kiev it would
be a big deal now he's just taking it
all at once to get it out get it over
with before people from the looks of the
map it looks like the entire country
yeah he's gonna take the whole thing and
then it's gonna be done and it's gonna
be russia
why would he stop
because the world will declare war on
them no they won't i think they will
he's already so you have no choice yeah
yeah who the united states britain
france germany um all these people that
are relying on cheap energy turkey
probably will get this is the chinese
will be on the russian side absolute
torture for everybody it's this
entanglement of everybody's interests
you know you have you have europe
relying on russia for a tremendous
amount of cheap energy are they going to
be so quick to declare war
well this is the crazy thing the the
idea for so long was that trade would
stop war it's what the neocons and
neo-liberal establishment thought they
were going to do they said we'd do a
free trade agreement with china and then
we'll have peace because no one will
want to go to war instead what happens
is the bully in the room says i'll go to
war and i get your stuff and ain't
nothing you can do about it yep yeah
it works a little true but it doesn't
stop war
it helps get people get to know each
other but that's it gives you an
incentive to work together but it
doesn't stop conflict no it doesn't
because there's always workarounds in a
global economy there's always
workarounds you can slap russia with
sanctions but guess what when china has
their back how much do those sanctions
actually mean yeah like if they get
kicked off the swift payment system did
that we already touched on that story no
we're getting into next in a second yeah
that's i mean that's
talk about a new banking
regime but i i i think
right now you've got germany they didn't
want the sanctions on uh nordstrom too
because they want the gas they want the
energy they need it yeah now they have
no choice because vladimir putin's like
i literally don't care i got you by the
balls if you need our gas we can take
what we want it's one of the reasons the
us was like hey we should be working
with our western allies to move this
pipeline up from you know the cutter
turkey pipeline through syria but all of
that does all that does
if vladimir putin has control over your
energy and then you say we're going to
screw with your allies and build a
pipeline to shut your your your monopoly
on energy down they're going to be like
you know i can see you doing that right
that's going to happen like putin's like
i'm watching you attack my interests i'm
not gonna sit back and let you do i used
to play a lot of civilization and in the
game sometimes i would choose to be like
a trade heavy net uh country and i'd
have all these trade networks all over
the world but then every once in a while
the world would be like we're gonna take
we're going to war and as soon as the
person would go towards me all my trades
would end abruptly i'd be bankrupt i'd
have no income i'd have no
leather i'd have no
basically if you're relying on trade and
you go to war with your trade partner
you're getting done yeah you're saying
you're bad at civilization is that what
it is well i learned the hard way i got
good the hard way
in civilization it's a video game is
energy independence no you take the furs
from them with guns well that's one
option if you're playing that kind of i
never play civilization that way yeah i
always i always have really strong
borders a really strong and advanced
military and i mind my own business it's
like a novelty i go forward that is a
novel concept
can you say that one more time for us
this is how i i i isn't it you know this
is really funny though do you win a lot
when you play oh yeah every time but but
i go for science and cultural victory
which is there's different ways to win
so
you know i had a buddy and um he
introduced me to fallout 3.
so i'm playing fallout 3 if you ever
play fallout yeah game first so when i
whenever i play it you know what i go
for i go for stealth sniper
sneak lock pitch so dangerous yeah
that's how i play the game i never get
in any direct conflicts i see a super
mutant i'm in the bushes and slow motion
vats gotta get some power armor in case
hold on my buddy
when he's playing the game
he runs in guns blazing heavy weapons
that's how i played metal gear hit five
wait wait hold on check it out he was a
marine
yeah and so i'm like you know what like
the mentality of the person comes out
you know it's expressed in the way they
play these games his view was go in guns
are blazing shut it down quick and fast
and control the situation mine was sneak
around slowly take your time be patient
very different personalities when i play
civilization
you can see my mentality and all this
stuff i don't like war
mind my own business peace and
prosperity and that's how i play the
game
we i build up my my cities i make
everyone live really great lives we do
tech we do we research and technology
what do you do and we mine our own
business what do you do if someone
attacks you in the game we wipe them out
strong
it's a strong it's a strong defense
though
i never initially i'll go if i get
attacked i go completely ballistic and
wipe them off the face of the earth yeah
like i don't i don't just sue for peace
i i eradicate the species well well
in civilization if you do that all the
other countries and they think i'm a
warmonger but it's like you know what
you deserve it because you're a war you
attacked me that's a crazy mentality and
i'm afraid that humans have that
mentality look like real life i'm
playing a game i got my little country
you know my land my people have settled
they come to my borders and they say
give me your stuff and i say don't try
it don't try it they try it they get
crushed i go into their cities i occupy
them
and then when everyone gets mad at me i
say i don't care stay the f away from my
borders leave me alone and you'll have
no problems
i i like that mentality america can have
all the nukes in the world it can be the
most powerful mfr on the planet and it
can sit back with its feet up and be
like dude we're chilling you guys leave
us alone and we're good that was the
original idea right that's how they
invented iraq or afghanistan yeah i mean
we got we got it wrong way before we
hawaii wilson yeah it was before we used
it was invaded
to we colonized hawaii we invaded hawaii
and took it over from the natives we
invaded wake island and midway island
like we we were one of those one of
those conquistador countries like with
britain and france and all them yeah but
the you know the the original idea was
that we we set out to be isolationists
we
we we conquered obviously
from
c to c
and then we said okay this is this is
our spot here now and
we're not gonna go
you know around the world but we're
gonna show it off
you know they they sell they sell the
navy around the world originally
the great white fleet or whatever i
believe it was called um you know
because to show off our might but then
it went back to our borders and that's
realistically that's that should be the
purpose of a military you know what
would have enabled us to maintain our
isolationist policies would have been to
have developed some form of energy
independence because this is a problem
in germany they decided to shut down
their nuclear plants because they had a
whole lot of green guilt from a little
swedish girl and now they rely so
heavily on russian gas they can't live
without it they're literally talking
about blackouts and brownouts during the
winter in germany because they shut down
their nuclear power plants and they rely
so heavily and when they sanction russia
it is going to be a dark and cool
well freedom is about
self-dependence right if you if you
can't stand on your own two feet whether
that be uh at the level of a country or
all the way down to the individual you
can't be free unless you can tell
somebody to piss off and since that you
don't need them and that you'll do it
yourself yes and and we need to have
that as a if we're going to adopt that
mentality as a country we can't be
reliant upon china russia anybody for
energy we have to be able to stand on
our own two feet and say we're not
getting involved but if you come to our
borders you will find out this is like i
got
by this if you think nuclear energy is
too dangerous but you're willing to
threaten a nuclear war power for oil
for your energy you've missed the plot
see the problem nuclear power is less
dangerous it's safer than attacking
russia thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you